julie delpy on va voir si vous avez une
chance de former une famille
vous faire l'interview in vitro
[Rires]
dans la donnée par amour les habitués
connaissent un grand classique de
l'émission parce que par un mur je crois
que ce soir ça s'impose est-ce que par
amour vous êtes prête à cacher quelqu'un
qu'il vient de tuer
eux
n'ont pas ce que j'aurais peur qu'ils me
tuent voyez enfin je veux dire
toi tu es quelqu'un qui vient du cash
j'ai des problèmes avec le crime je
pense que le plus brillant mais en même
temps tu as la première question
répondons déjà c est ce que vous êtes
prête un amant julie delpy à vous mettre
aux drogues dures non
est-ce que vous êtes prêts soit à faire
aucun effort
est ce que vous êtes prête à prendre 17
kg par amour bah oui ça c'est le poids
d'un bébé est-ce que par amour alors là
c'est évidemment la question de clotilde
courau qui a épousé cette semaine la
question d'apprécier sa vie la question
note française rend compte qu'en fait m
c'est lui les princes de venise et quand
il avait lancé son parfum tu l'avais dit
qu'il était peut-être de bandol et
bien voilà c'est plein de souvenirs
qu'on a on leur souhaite beaucoup de
bonheur aux deux tourtereaux est-ce que
donc comme clotilde courau vous seriez
prête à embrasser cent fois ses
chaussettes sales
sales mais pourquoi je ferais ce à quoi
par amour
on choisit pas vous savez mes salles de
basket salle de chaussures en cuir de
prince avec des chaussettes ben dis donc
alors aux voix fouet pas vraiment bat
julie moi je me poserai plus la question
après cette interview vous refusez tous
et non non non j'ai dit oui les
chaussettes
comme ça oui comme ça bon alors est-ce
que par amour vous accepteriez julie
quelques petites infidélités
si moi aussi je peux être infidèle oui
sans problème un papa koly staff donc
est-ce que vous accepteriez par amour
qu'il est une maîtresse
ça oui je moi ça me pose pas de problème
ouais vous avez trouvé la
salle et pas cher
c'est bien
la fidélité est une chose qui me
semblent abstraites en fait dans un
couple la durée non de que les choses
sur la mecque pour les deux amants pour
les deux c'est déjà plus embêté c'était
comme ça toi jean jacques toi dans ton
couple vous acceptez des non pas d'un
fil et non non non sûrement pas non tu
es capable de tuer un chasseur
il faut 7 discret je pense un ace que
par amour vous seriez prête à vivre à
trois avec sa maîtresse
sympa la maîtresse a amusé en fait la
vaisselle felli toussaint pas vraiment
la maîtresse cool
mais déjà je sais pas si j'accepterais
de vivre avec la personne parce que la
main le mec des charges j'aimerais mieux
qu'ils ceux qui vivent ensemble à ce que
moi j'ai un appartement séparer voyez
pour moi ça me conviendrait mieux à deux
avec la maîtresse non pas du tout
si c'est juste une copine oui c'est très
bien non non non non j'aimerais mieux
être seule en fait
c'est le seul il peut aller avec sa
maîtresse vrai que sa maîtresse ça ne
dérangerait pas de fait pour toi un
chien des trois mois je
n'ai pas compatible avec la bêche en
geste par amour ah non non ça non bon
mais j'étais tout seul
non les clubs échangistes il ya quelque
chose d'un peu cradingue quoi écouter
les gens qui se connaissent pas
pour partir il faut connaître les gens
d'où ils viennent quelles sont leurs
formations sinon je suis pas du tout par
tous dans ça n'a rien du tout est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à devenir
son esclave sexuelle
c'est quoi une être une esclave sexuelle
magnéto
bon oui pendant quelques temps quand
même temps
aux
jets pas quelques mois mais donc ça
passe parce que
non non non ça non c'est pas possible
c'est mal barré très mal barré dernière
question je suis parce qu'un panier
est-ce que par un mot vous seriez prête
à vendre votre corps pour lui non
vous êtes prêté un rien travail en amont
et vous avez vos questions cette année
c'est des questions de la vie c'est les
questions et vous jeu pour tourner
qu'est ce que vous êtes prêts à vendre
votre corps par amour ouais mais si ma
femme et je fais un serment solennel
sociale oui ma femme me demande de
vendre mon corps par amour je le fais ok
de baiser avec
je ne sais pas si non à sarkozy par
exemple à s'arrêter
si ma femme me demande je le fasse et
beaucoup mais l'amour voilà j'ai pas mal
enfin
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu